you notice one of them seems a little
unhappy now is the time to assess his or
her mental health before they head back
to school in the New Year here with some
warning signs is pediatric psychologist
Dr Timothy yeiter from Nevada mental
health thank you so much for joining us
thanks for having me let's talk about
this I have children do you have
children also oh I say I have hundreds
of children hundreds of children yeah
what do you what do you do when you see
that your child is abruptly changing
their routine
so you want to always compare it to what
have they been like before is this brand
new is this behavior that you've never
seen before that could be an indicator
that something new was going on that
they might be suddenly suffering from
something like depression or anxiety so
that change is what you're looking for
what are some of those changes that you
might see so skipping out on family
activities right whether it's family
meals going out to stores together
starting to isolate in their room and
spending all their time there rather
than with a family can be an indicator
of depression what are other indicators
of depression or anxiety that we should
be on the lookout for so irritability
um crankiness being a little snappier
than usual which could be hard to gauge
in a teenager sometimes yeah exactly but
that irritability can be a sign of both
depression and anxiety now what about
physical sickness where they're
constantly getting sick or they're you
know they're they're saying they don't
feel good is that something we should be
aware of too very very tricky in today's
day and age with the kovids and the rsvs
so it's hard to know but the mind-body
connection is very real so when you
start having unexplained headaches real
just general stomach pains with no real
cause that can be that Mind Body giving
you a heads up if there's a high level
of anxiety that nervous stomach can be
an upset stomach and so that can also be
an indicator of anxiety in young people
if you feel that your child is suffering
from anxiety or depression what are the
next steps how how do we get them help
so reach out to your community there's a
lot of great providers out there Nevada
mental health has a lot of services that
people can access but really just find
someone who you can talk to to just get
an assessment to be like hey is this
typical is this you know something
that's short-lived or something more
more concerning that needs more in-depth
look great advice and